J to anyone else who wants to pitch
their own show ideas to HBO or another
cable outlet does it take certain
connections or can anyone just off the
street Cole call HBO and just set up a
meeting I don't I don't know for sure
but I imagine it's pretty pretty tough
to get your foot in the door at like a
fully established network if you don't
have a body of work behind you that kind
of subpoena shows that you know you can
carry a movie or carry a show from
beginning to fruition but I still do
believe that anything can happen and
that you know most people are looking
for inspired new ideas I think that the
tricky part of that equation is they're
also looking for an inspired new way to
execute it and so that's just as much
what they're looking for as an inspired
idea so you know might might take a
little a little history to get you in
that door why are we seeing all this
young talent yourself included Shawn
Durkin Cary Fukunaga Lena Dunham and
others turning to cable TV and other
outlets for their work well I can't
speak for other people but for us you
know the the main reason that we've
recently turned to HBO is is you know
for one we had a we had an idea that
that we thought was more appropriate for
long-form just something that we could
carry out forever and we could do really
subtle amazing things so that that's a
huge advantage and I think you know the
other advantages are you know just
having a having regular work and you
know people we're doing a show at HBO
and Los Angeles and people are thrilled
to be living at home and doing a show
that they really love and care about and
for some reason you know I think I think
it's really the viewership that's
driving it people are watching more
stuff on HBO people are watching stuff
on Netflix and on Amazon so it's it's
the scope of distribution is changing
and I think the filmmakers are following
suit
you